Europe loses between five point eight
and nine point six billion euros every
year in public procurement due to the
lack of whistleblower protection only
about ten EU countries currently protect
whistleblowers MEP s have reached an
agreement with EU governments on
comprehensive legal protection so that
whistleblowers feel safe to report
illegal or unethical activity on what is
a suki de fondo PR they know something
else
a newly formed in the from the democracy
of a pendulum tentative opener only
Parliament ever would be on the wrong
problem into the new rules will widen
the scope of who is protected by the law
the NGOs and journalists who help
whistleblowers will also benefit and
it's not just in cases of tax evasion
like with the lux leak scandal
whistleblowers should be protected
regardless of the type of violation
whether it's in finance the environment
politics or personal data protection
news every point on Sunday after they do
the job in protection control legal fees
are you don't run equally keep you see
in protection duty clocks californiaís
the box with the measures include the
creation of safe channels so
whistleblowers can report wrongdoing
without fear of reprisals and greater
assistance like free legal advice and
psychological support the text also
provides safeguards against suspension
and demotion and introduces financial
compensation should a whistleblower be
dismissed from their job
[Music]